days after Lindsay Lohan live-streamed a
video on Instagram in which she accused
a homeless family of trafficking their
children a source close to Lohan tells
et that family and friends of the actors
are worried about her and want her to
return to the United States tell me your
stories that we can help you what do you
need what do you need in the since
deleted Instagram video from Friday
night Lindsay speaking English Russian
and Arabic becomes infuriated and
tearful when a homeless family refuses
her help after the family gets up and
walks away the actress then trails them
throwing out this allegation what's
happening they're trafficking children a
family source tells ET her family wants
her back in New York because that's
where they are based out of a second
source close to Lohan believes New York
is not the best place for the 32 year
old saying quote she has a close friend
who believes she should live with him in
Cincinnati Ohio the friend in Ohio could
keep her safe and away from the chaos of
the paparazzi that she would run into in
New York Cincinnati is quiet the source
adds it would be difficult for Lohan to
move back to the u.s. because her
businesses are all in Greece and she's
also in the middle of production for her
new reality show in 2017
Lindsay told us why she loves living
overseas I love living in New York but I
do love the serenity and peace that I
find living in the Middle East because
there are no cameras in Dubai and I
can't actually focus on what I want to
do in life and I don't have to always be
scrutinized every second so I can have a
private life and and have a public life
but when I choose to and I think that's
really important and with all the social
media
these days it's really impossible to
have that here and I'm 31 so I'm not
getting any younger
et has reached out to Lohan's rep for
comment
[Music]